and driver Private Viktor
Eslib Tuev Russian Federation the first crew
on a yellow tank the first crew of the
Republic of Uzbekistan
the tank commander senior sergeant is not
back Yuldashev the gunner operator captain
ushkin shamuratov and the driver
sergeant 3rd degree avazbek mustafa call
of uzbekistan the first crew and
on the left  on the flank I am on the 4th track a red tank the
first crew of the team of the
People's Republic of China
tank commander a sergeant low worms gunner
operator sergeant Martian not a
driver senior sergeant you
fight so friends crews presented
at the command of the chief judge of the competition
tank biathlon major general
alexander glazkov crew  they will take a
position in the tanks, but for now, 1 horn sounds
at the tank biathlon and
[music]
so this is the team for taking the places of
regular places in the combat vehicles of the t-72b
tank three type 96 tanks would be all tanks all the
teams participating in the tank biathlon it
takes part tanks  Russian-
made Russian st  The defense
provides all crews
with T-72 b3 tanks in full, but at the same time, in
accordance with the rules of the competition, the
team can participate on its own
vehicles.
The Chinese team uses this opportunity.
declared power of 1000 horsepower
per t-72b tank 3,840 horsepower also of the
national team of the republic of belarus advances on
t-72b 3 tanks but already in
service with their republic they come
with tanks and participate on their equipment,
so now just a few seconds at the
pit and how  since it’s the last moment at the judge’s tower, the
chief judge’s briefing is the
first to start the measure of the Russian
Federation the first crew friends will support
our team well, well, not just
definitely not just step through first,
you need to set the highest bar and the
first obstacles that await
tankers on the track individual races
this is the maneuvering area smeak
not  the most difficult  an obstacle at the
same time, of course, Kirov's turn needs
to be dealt with with emotions with nerves that
may now be present in the
body of our tankers and all
tankers, the whole country, the whole world is watching
now and today Nathan will buy a forehead
, now our
team, driver-mechanic,
victor tuev, is coping with the first obstacle  task raises the white
flag dust referee at each
obstacle friends placed field
referees who observe the procedure for
passing obstacles overcoming
obstacles if the obstacle is overcome
correctly then the field orbit he raises the
white flag if there was a violation then the direct
referee raises the red flag and in this
case the main housing of the competition sends the
team  to the pit stop site of the penalty
time, we hope that this will not be a
single team, but we will return to this a
little later.  ba from so you cannons
at targets number 12, the meshes imitate
an enemy tank, the range to the target is
1600 1700 and 1800 meters,
so the loading of the ammunition is completed, but it’s
not the nose
for this task
, our tankers
literally in a matter of seconds loaded
3 regular artillery rounds
with a caliber of 125 millimeters and occupied
firing position for firing and
so the first shot Michel green the
target is struck brilliant work our
coaching and our coaching staff was now
on the screens so attention 2 target in the
field and now it rises
that the gunner operator beats the search for the target
and as soon as the target is detected opens
fire
her target is hit at the very edge, the very
edge down the target is now hit by our
crew, well, so as not to be afraid not
to raise it or you need to hit it right in the heart with the
target in the middle of the target
3 interfere with a range of
1700 meters shot
her target well, well, brilliant work the first
crew of the bravo bra from the guy ahead  along the
route of the competition track tank battle well
Well, don’t relax ahead of two more
fire missions, the national team of Uzbekistan at this
time, start
at the time on the stopwatch, I start
counting from each team,
put on the stopwatch, of course, each
team has its own counter, but we understand that the
start is not simultaneous, as if there
simply cannot be one counter, and so on
presenting the first obstacle smeak
performed by the national team of uzbekistan the first
crew the driver
of the uzbekistan team is
quite cocky
military personnel 28 years old usa 3 a class in
aspect mustafu tones
passes the obstacles with ease and raises the
white flag
without violations the obstacles
ahead are overcome loading three regular
artillery shots before
performing 1  the fire mission on the screens of
our tank t-72b tripe has already presented
obstacles to the area minus the nom
barrier, and now the gunner
operator brilliantly coped with the task
on the screens, it’s not even the magician of alkanes,
our him, but
95 where the native of the Chita region was born, the
power of the moon now lives
in  version of the Trans-Baikal Territory ladies pass
over the service by nationality Buryat we are
still on the feet of the national team to
friends and there is also Buryatia Russian Georgians
Ukrainians, but what is certainly all the guys
from one of our vast vast motherland
loaded ammunition and Uzbek tanks
if now, according to the report of the tank commander on
completion  loads of ammunition
continue to move out to the first
firing position
so the crew stops, it is necessary
to report to the tank commander near the
tank commander readiness, my friends, do not
forget that since last year additional ammunition has been provided for the
first division,
if page
does not hit Michel
, now just the same antifreeze moment
my friends there is no raid, we see that a
projectile is now hitting the bro spheres, this
suggests that the national team of uzbekistan will have to
use at least one
more additional ammunition, and so 2 michelles
in the field of
1700 meters
take a closer look at the same
time the russian team rushes past
where we are  we’ll be back a little later
until the second shot
es el well, the adjuster operator is going
to hit the target
and one more target will be pavel they want it
now it’s already
standing perfectly visible on the screens of the target of the
corresponding color to the
light so the color was determined the day before at the
draw on August 16 and so it won’t fly
this was not given to the friends of the Uzbek disputed, they
will have to use two penalty
ammunition, and just the same, now
the crew is leaving the tank
as a whole, indicating the formation, after that it
is loading
regular artillery rounds, after
that again they are struck, the decision will be
raised, the crew will fire on them
and already in the case  if and using
additional ammunition the team does not
hit the target it will have to go through
penalty loops two penalty loops on the
right left flank of 500 meters the
distance of each penalty loop but on
average about a minute spends time in the
repeat moment now just the
same effective only
obligation is a successful shot
uzbekistan national team the first crew
coped with one goal the
team of the People's Republic of China
goes to the track of the competition the first
crew well we wish good luck to the chinese team a
very strong team yes all
teams are strong friends and most
teams out of 19 this year emphasize 19
teams last year there were 16
all very  prepared for the first time participating
in our moth, but nevertheless, pray
too,
like all of them for the first time, because the camp in
Yamal, which will be presented in
the tank biathlon competition,
you are cadets undergoing training at the
Far Eastern Higher Combined Arms
Command School, and so a
shot from the
EU or Uzbekistan strikes
that  a target that did not try to
say so and led out
to take an additional artillery
shot so Michel in the field
[music] the
adjuster the operator
managed to shamuratov got together well well
done guys the first crew of uzbekistan
still copes with the task of the pulse with
additional running out of ammunition before
wasted time but nevertheless
there will be no penalty loops, continues to move along
the competition track, there are 2 more fire
tasks ahead and the national team of uzbekistan, in fact,
like each team, but the
people’s republic of china, loading 3
artillery rounds,
as the team of the russian federation tells me now, is
already loading
ammunition into an anti-aircraft machine gun port, I
think now  we will be shown our guys but for
now let's look
at the team of the chinese doom at the same time yes
now I will simultaneously show it to the
national team of russia and the chinese team of the
russian federation loaded
ammunition machine gun court shooting will
be carried out by our tank commander
alexander namsaraev
so the shot with the breed of the
people's republic of china
has seven targets hit  1600
after all, at which the shooting was carried out, the shooting was carried
out from an anti-aircraft machine
gun 12.7 caliber court
2 decide there
is a search for
closers of pirates I have something
with the tank let
[applause]
this is a direct field referee now
there are friends of my team of the
People's Republic of China on the strip second  th
shot and michel hit the team of the
russian federation is coping with the task
of hitting targets number 25 helicopter
my friends with effective live
firing shooting fires fire but I
would like to say right away that the
weather wants to be damp tonight my daughter was walking
yes it happens that way there
is simply no fire
at the same time, the field referee reports that
Michelle was struck like the team of the
People's Republic of China now we
see a breakdown of write non-red
penal ammunition and penalty sleeves for the Chinese
team will not necessarily be after
each race, the entire
judging panel of the races is put forward for
inspection of the target  an obligatory condition
prescribed in the regulation on the tank biathlon competition, the
rules of the tank
biathlon, and after that, once again everyone is
convinced of the effectiveness, or both, on the
contrary, the combat shooting is not effective,
and at the meeting of the judging
panel, which takes place every day,
sit down at the Alabino training ground, and
casa  finally, but in general, in general, to
friends, and as practice shows, the
results that you yourself see on the
screens of the
race, they remain after the
pages if
but about but if now the crew roots are
uzbekistan and bakugan words let's
see the time cutoff
take seconds and uzbekistan lag behind
anyone  draste to the federation for 4 minutes
obstacles, let's say, do not cause much
difficulty for our of this
[music]
team of the russian federation our green
so continues to move
passed the kurgans the crew of the russian
federation the team of the people's
republic of china well, in fact, the trace is following,
but just let's note that the team of the
russian federation is already  completes the
second lap but you actually
started first
in front of our crew another
fire mission on the third lap here is a
limited passage a difficult
obstacle because the crew comes out of a
deep turn and overcomes this
obstacle with a nose really from such a
serious turn and it happens that the
mechanics drives  if they make mistakes,
knocking down restrictive ones, I would remind you
if a mistake was made when overcoming
one or another obstacle of any of the
obstacles, the crew goes to the
penalty area where they perform the
standard control inspection of the car,
spending about 1 minute on this, and
now we see the white flag is raised by the
field referee, the Chinese team  the first
crew to coped with the obstacles of the
anti-tank ditch, like our team, are
now passing by the circle to the glory of winding
you and greet our
team, our guys perform 1
12 minutes
1 second,
but put our crew in the
individual race, so China
618 is 53 seconds behind the
Russian team with friends and  what a good jump
prevents and it’s not easy here on the
knee of the bridge and not in any case the site of the
rock is literally a few centimeters to the
left or to the right and the tank is already descending
rather it is considered a violation of the procedure for
overcoming obstacles in front of the comb
riddick child’s friends and now
after the combs  ki last year it was
here that the area in the
minefields was located in accordance with the rules of
this year, he moved
in front of the obstacle in the mouth now
there is a site of minefields
so so yellow y brutal
team loading ammunition anti-aircraft machine gun
court shooting room number 25 so  we
heard
when performing this fire mission, the
crew stops, exits the combat
vehicle and then builds up a
period of 15 rounds of them, 6
tracer bullets
after that, the tank commander reports
readiness for firing and, at the command of the judge
, a target imitating an enemy helicopter is raised
just the same anti-aircraft machine gun
courts from  its main purpose is the
fight against low-flying air
targets, which
can be a helicopter, and so shooting
my friends, the commander of the
tank, the team’s smiles, is firing, this is the sergeant,
Yuldashev is no longer running,
36-year-old already experienced military personnel
participates in the biathlon tank for the second time,
but the
weapon is clearly discharged  the
tank commander is now reporting debatably Uzbekistan, but
unfortunately there wasn’t a target
hit a little lower, the tank commander took it
and the decision remained intact, so
the Chinese team stops at the
ammunition loading area for firing from an
anti-aircraft machine gun, that’s just the same formation
, indicating now the crew
of the Chinese people’s team  of the republic,
look at the coordination of actions the
chief judge of the competition, I am Major
Glazkov, means one penalty
loop, the national team of Uzbekistan, Misha number 25, was not
hit, I think it will
be repeated again much later, the shooting of the national team of
Uzbekistan, but for now,
the tank commander is reporting that
they saw ready to open fire ready to open
the fire of things has already been raised in the field of things
and now the tank commander is shooting
Chinese teams of the 1st type sergeant of low
worms a
native of the city I will unscrew the
26-year-old tank commander for the first time
participating in the tank biathlon competition at
the same time there is a bear number 9 3 of the
hero of the task for the national team  of the Russian
Federation Puri to fire our gunner
operator shooting is being carried out and a coaxial
machine gun with a caliber of 762 millimeters, but for
now, on the screens, the commander is like this with a bear,
look at my friends free sand and
finishes it off us, the gunner operator of the target is
glass, you can clearly see when the target was
hit it was older on dashi him
account  for 26 years from the natives of the
Chita region to our gunner, the
operator who did an excellent job with the
first nail task shooting at
targets number 12, but also actually an
excellent job and the
top was smashed to smithereens target number
9 the
team of the People's Republic of China
earned one penalty loop at this
time you have to go an additional 500
meters  and our crew of the 1st type completed three
fire missions, now all hope for
the driver is more closely
needed now the ordinary viktor chips that his
young friends my 22 years old victor
for the first time participate my tastes tank
biathlon then we have all the members of the team
for the first time participate for the first time in accordance  and
with the instructions of the Minister of Defense of the Russian
Federation, the
hero of the Russian Federation, General of the
Army Sergei Kuzhugetovich
Shoigu, every year the team is
renewed by 100 percent of each
soldier of the tanker there is a chance
to take part in the Tartu
biathlon throughout the year there are qualifying
competitions starting from military units
to trade
further 9 districts, that is  in
fact, it’s not just the
same to determine the
federation that participates in the competition,
such a branch of the
team of uzbekistan,
that
now there’s an obstacle like mine-explosive barriers now,
here
’s ours, and according to the federation’s sausage and
pulls
leggings,
I’m a country now looking at you a good
result to friends and  and while our
team has 1759 18 minutes a
year ago, the Russian team has the best result
with a full individual race of
17 minutes 47 seconds while this is a teacher while
I have a smoke break for friends and whether any
of the crews of our team will be able to
show the result even better this year we will find out
during this  week  whether during this
week all the individual races will go
from
today to Sunday
inclusive, the
individual race with friends, but
starting from Tuesday, September 31, the
semi-final races of the relay race will take place,
but it will be a little later, for now, let's
return to the competition track our team
will already be completing this race in a few
moments and the teams of the
People's Republic of China are gaining very
good speed installed gps
trackers in each tank we can
observe in real time the
speed of the tank 71 kilometers 72 kilometers
per hour 76 showed the crew of the
People's Republic of China but I will remind  while the
record in tank biathlon
is the speed set by our
crews last year in 2019,
eighty-four kilometers per hour,
so friends, we are the Chinese team passing by the
brother this time, the Russian Federation national team
brings greetings to the finish line,
but
our first crew, the Russian teams,
completed the high  dullness
19 minutes thirty-six minutes on the screen the
coach of our national team
major ilnar sagdiev eastern military
district more recently a participant in the
tank biathlon of the first tank in the
biathlon of 2013 but this is not our
cassation here and not our
dear tankers thanks guys thanks
for the wonderful race thanks for the
really high  the bar that you
managed to show the eastern military district
foreman alexander namsaraev
tank commander driver mechanic ordinary
victor chips tuev and the adjuster operator the foreman
didn’t even lag the dans you were a father and the whole
country is proud of you
performs a military greeting of
course applauds and greetings now our
guys deputy minister of defense
of the Russian Federation, the
hero of the Russian Federation,
Lieutenant General Ilyichev Kurov, of
course, and the Commander-in-Chief of the Ground
Forces, today our guys are supported here by the
ideal army, Oleg Leonidovich
Selyukov, and well,
our coaches, and later
our tower,
our coaches, the chief judge of the competition
before  teams of the people's republic of
china return to the track of the competition time 14
minutes 28 seconds cutoff after
overcoming 2 laps left on the chinese
team one more firing line one more
firing task shooting from a coaxial
machine gun of caliber 7 62 millimeters
increase number 9 1 target you do not
rise individual write jesus
rule  Well, what are you going to sing to friends and there will be
much more targets there will be three targets 9 there
will also be a Michel of an
anti-tank gun and shooting will be
flank and a headquarters and guns Well, the
relay race is definitely and brighter spectacular
because all the crews participate, but
nevertheless the individual standings must
pass  In general, I consider it to be friends and
more spectacular than the competition tank biathlon,
but probably there is not a single type of
competition in general firepower
adrenaline that gets into the blood of the
fans incomparable with any of these
sports, well, forgive me the athletes,
but they also discussed this topic with many
guests of the Olympic tank biathlon
champions dey  Indeed, they say that this
is something simply incredible. In
2013, for the first time, at the initiative of the Minister of
Defense of the Russian Federation and the
Russian Federation, General of the Army
Sergey Kuzhugetovich Shoigu,
the tank competition 50 was born here at the
Alabino training ground,
only four teams met in
it, but this year it’s already 19  no limit this is no
limit I'm sure the team is interested
observers are coming watching us from
all over the world and
continues to
participate continues to arrive countries
participating in the competition as a whole this year 34
competitions of the seventh army
international games the official opening of the
army games will take place tomorrow in the
military-patriotic park of culture and
recreation patriot  and so the national team of uzbekistan
video shooting at target number nine
targets spots are excellent the range to the target is
700 meters and the
target is its target to friends and it was the adjuster
operator the national team of uzbekistan
captain pushkin noise uratov
31 years old is not the first time already participating in the
tank biathlon competition
more you are watching now
for  the team, of course, is a thing for Uzbekistan
and supports her beloved husband, the wife of
Nargiz and the daughter of Nurzhamal, the
team of Uzbekistan shows very good
results and participates in the
third year, we will see that the team already started in the
first division from the second all
teams participating for the first time get into the
second division
for the third year already  teams of the
tank biathlon competition are divided into two
divisions corresponding to the rating of
previous years this year in the first
division 11 teams Russia China
Belarus Azerbaijan Kazakhstan Mongolia
Uzbekistan Serbia Venezuela
Syria  at this time, the
tank commander, the
tank commander of the People's Republic of China, is now reporting
that the weapon is unloaded, but
we see that Michel is safe and sound, the
whole and unharmed infographic
helps us to observe the
effectiveness of the execution of fire,
but fire missions, the
target is displayed in the form
a soldier with a hand
-held anti-tank grenade launcher, but
remained safe and sound, the team of the
People's Republic of China will go
through a penalty loop against the background of two penalty loops 500
meters long each of them to which
penalty loop and the team should go to
determine the chief judge of the competition,
you need to be very careful in terms of
movement along the track  in no case
avoid a collision, therefore it may
happen that the crew did
not cope with this task
on the left flank, but it will pass insure the
station to the right, I will take one
that brings the crews the chief judge of the
competition now at the nearest [ __ ] the
original
now is also a good chance to
break into second position  in this
race, well, so far, the time is 22 minutes 57
seconds, and the team media cyst is on from the
start, starting from the start of the china team
from 19 minutes 17-18 seconds, the
Russian Federation has already performed with the
result of 1936, hitting five targets out of
five
so deep a turn going up or
here  understand  more than a driver, it
brings tanks in; remind the T-72b 346 tank; the
weight of this formidable military equipment, which has
proven itself as one of the
best tanks in the ordinary world again,
friends uralvagonzavod conscientiously
fulfills the state order to
build tanks makes them the armed
forces of the Russian Federation and other countries
uralvagonzavod is one of the largest
machine-building enterprises in russia a
recognized leader in world tank building by the
way, my friends this year
uralvagonzavod is answering its 85th
biography and
[music]
lubricate its
targets out of 5
I remind you to make
it hurt terribly
after the race the entire composition of the judging
commission of each race is put forward in
cars to the targets and inspect
personally  take pictures and, in fact,
closes all controversial points, all
controversial issues that
can only appear. In general, refereeing for a
year
has never had any complaints and the chief
referee of the competition is not in general to the judges
from each country, the judge enters the referee's
stone, etc.  my friends, therefore, 19 countries 19
judges from each state, including the
Russian Federation, you are the chief judge of the
competition,
and
at least who
caress and poured obstacles
anti-tank ditch
artists of the People's Republic of China
this magician curved orbit
[music]
or shields tens of meters to the finish line
pen climbed
21 so full of attention  finish on the
People's Republic of China in this
race on the second line 21 minutes
fifty-four seconds three targets out of
five were hit by the Russian team
1936 china 2154 uzbekistan
2416 must be taken again we thank the
tankers of the first race that's right
now on the screens the first crew of the
Chinese people's  republics let's
remember these guys emotions very well
coped with the excitement showed
demonstrated their skills
tank commander sergeant low worms
serviceman operator sergeant martian and
driver senior sergeant
people bravo china bravo uzbekistan and the
russian federation all great fellows
my friends today  I will also take place and the
first race of the second division will take place
literally in a few moments
in one hour tells me now the
chief judge of the competition will take place the
second race of this day sheep but this is the
first race for the second division in
which the first crews of laos
kyrgyzstan moth debutants of this year will meet and I
would  an hour, friends of May, the first
race of the second division will take place, we have
just watched the performances of one of the
strongest kopat dotku and from where russia
china a piece of dough again time
1936 seconds 8 at 1 kilometer per hour
showed the best result
in speed the team of the russian federation
in china you 56 kilometers  an hour and 20
such 54 and uzbekistan 75 kilometers
charger
you need it even
or was a captain so rich in
nikolaevich good we will hear very
soon the threshold thank you for your attention everyone
good mood be happy
be healthy tank biathlon villages all
to the training ground all over